hey metaphysical milkshake it's me rain
wilson and it is hi reza aslan hi raine
hi uh wait what's your name again
reza reza you've met me many many times
we've been working together for multiple
years
reza that's persian right
yes it is and the and reza means what
does it mean it means like king right uh
no it does not actually it does not mean
king it means um
uh satisfactory
actually
so your name really is satisfactory asl
it's it's more complicated than that
reza is the persian version of the
arabic word riddha and
uh yeah riddha basically means uh
he who is satisfactory
[Laughter]
so that's me okay i am uh
satisfactory thank you everyone
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way
presented by cast media and soul pancake
so
you satisfactory aslan um
you ever played football you ever uh
bullied someone and beat the crap out of
them
uh you you've seen me right like you've
you've seen my physical phone you're
like four foot eleven
hold on now first of all i'm five foot
eight as my license uh says though
probably more like five foot six
you and tom cruise are five foot eight
honestly i was probably like 97 pounds
at night no i never bullied anyone okay
good i just wanted to make sure it
wasn't you because
uh this next episode you conveniently
couldn't be there
and so i interviewed my good friend the
artist
the rabble rouser the author the tv host
the larger than life personality mr
david cho david cho and he was bullied
by a kid named reza and the persian
mafia
at the beverly hills high school but i
just wanted to make sure it wasn't you
but um it wasn't me anyway i want to
show you the episode that we recorded
reza i'd love to get your hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold on hold on how are we talking about the
same david cho the the with the the the
guy with the show on fx called the cho
show yes the same show that the new york
post calls simultaneously weird and
compelling and yes cathartic for all
those concerned uh yes this is david cho
the street artist um
who
in exchange for painting a mural in
facebook instead of taking the money he
took the stock option
and let's just say he came out
ahead of the deal
uh world-renowned artist david cho no
honestly he's a good friend of mine i've
known him for a long time and he is one
of truly one of the most creative people
that i know creativity is just coming
out of his pores
um he's always writing painting
acting
um role-playing it it's it's a constant
um
it's a cornucopia of imagination and
creativity and so i thought who better
to explore one of the concepts that
we've always been really intrigued with
and we've touched on it in some other
episodes like with tignotaro
um
about comedy is like this is trauma
necessary
to be an artist does one need to be a
narcissist to be an artist does one need
to be a madman to be an artist well i
love this topic i can't wait to listen
to this i'm gonna play it for you um you
will uh you and all the other rezas are
gonna really enjoy some of these stories
and um let's get uh back together after
you've taken a look let's hear this
hi i'm marine wilson um even if you're
lactose intolerant your soul is not
welcome to metaphysical milkshake you
may know me from films as the rocker
where i actually learned how to play
drums or
uh the meg were actually
trained with sharks for weeks before i
did that or um
you may have read my memoir bassoon king
and
but that's not what we're here are we
gonna start this interview at some point
um
we have a brilliant artist here today a
brilliant artist who's um suffers from
adhd add all these things um he has a
show no no please do tell me more about
your bio
people really want to hear more about
the other movies
and the stuff that you did yeah it's
just fascinating dave i just i just want
to get the um listen cho you're on my
podcast i asked you here today okay and
uh let me just tell the audience who you
are okay so i have david cho here today
and he is a brilliant artist and he has
a show out right now on fx called the
cho show and to make it even more
confusing he has a podcast also called
the cho show
and he does a bunch of other things he
he he likes he likes to mess around
he likes to have fun very creative
person let's hear it for david joe and
[Applause]
that was that was the greatest
introduction i've ever had thanks
today we're here because we want to
discuss um creativity i mean david is
one of those people that brings uh art
to every creativity every part of his
life so
um i'll start i'll go first um you know
uh weird
parents plus weird name
equals weird kid
so that's me rain
um
i
played instruments like the xylophone
and the bassoon
and i played games of chance growing up
that involved 20-sided die
and um
you know choosing characters and so
uh my my mother abandoned me engines and
dragons is not a game of chance rain
there's there's
when you roll a dice you could uh well
that's true that's true if you hit a 20
then you know you've killed a an ogre
with a single crossbow bolt
right and as you know
people spend a lot of time investing in
their characters and sometimes when
their character dies it's like a part of
you dies so there's a lot invested i
relate to that um
my mother abandoned me when
i was young and my dad
took me to nicaragua so you can imagine
what that was like for me
and
even though i'm not korean i had a or i
still do have a large korean shaped head
and
and so you can imagine what the kids
made fun of me at
school and so there was a lot of trauma
there was a lot of neglect and
abandonment
my dad
you know my father was he would write
sci-fi stories and and paint
uh picasso-esque women with
lopsided breasts and
why why am i here
i'm just i'm trying to explain my side
and then i'll give you you don't have to
be this impatient you know um i'll i'll
i'm i'm trying to set you up i'm trying
to give you a foundation to come in
and so for me
uh all that i don't know how you measure
that neglect that that trauma that
abandonment but i knew when i got to
school when i finally took my first
drama class
that was the first time
i felt seen someone laughed at my jokes
someone gave me validation they clapped
when i acted so that's where i funneled
all my creativity into that
and
i'm just wondering for you where your
creativity comes from
uh okay
now it's my turn um
thanks rayne thanks for that
introduction yeah uh so i'm david cho
i'm an artist um
i mean it's hard to describe myself as
an artist because there's so much more
that i do than just art i don't want to
just be like a
you know a paint jockey just throwing
paint up on a canvas you know i try and
do more than that
and uh hence the various iterations of
the cho show
you know on television on fx and hulu
and
my podcast i did a live show called the
cho show that was an art installation
kind of interactive multimedia
uh
event
uh just so it's just a little bit more
about me i'm korean
um
my parents were immigrants i was
immigrant i was sent back to live in
korea when i was a kid
because um my family was so poor
my parents are born again christians so
you know when you see those korean buses
going around with like
korean lettering and it says like
church of the apostles of the seventh
day
you know and then with korean lettering
on the side like that was my family like
we would drive around in those vans
through koreatown and stuff like that
and
you know i just um
i think what you referenced uh rain is
that
uh his creativity and its connection to
trauma and
you know i don't know i don't know where
i stand on that i think there's a lot of
really good artists that
um haven't had any trauma
um and
seemingly and uh do really amazing work
you know but
for me
you know i don't know if i was born in
the in the in the suburbs and we were
kind of well off and my parents loved me
and and respected me and and
and kind of listened to me and and took
an interest in in who i was and didn't
you know weren't always trying to shame
me on trying to save my soul and you
know uh you know make sure i wasn't
involved in anything involving you know
sex or drugs or or pornography or you
know illicit materials such as comic
books of which i took an interest in at
a very early age i was about eight years
old uh you know who knows i might have
ended up um
you know i might have ended up really uh
more milk toast you know i don't i don't
know i might be uh sure sure i might be
a high school uh art teacher or who
knows maybe i just own a real estate
business
you know in in in van nuys
i don't know what that might have that
man
made your parents proud um
they'd probably be more proud of me if i
owned a real estate business
than being a successful
uh
artist deeply shameful from what i know
of the korean community deeply shameful
to say you want to pursue it i'm sorry
rain what do you know about the korean
community i i mean i i think that's
crazy i don't i don't think you know too
much about my faith but there is a
it's baha'i and there is actually a lot
of koreans that believe in baha'i so i
actually know a lot of koreans korean
baha'is there's korean baha'is and i get
asked to speak at their picnics and and
events all the time so i actually know a
lot about their culture
um well you can't know about a culture
because you haven't gave baha'i talks at
a korean baha'i picnic
well that's that's your opinion as a
korean all right and uh
you know when i first moved to la i
actually went to koreatown so i actually
know a lot about koreans and i've tried
kimchi before
and uh that that is impressive
look uh
before we dive into this further i just
want to apologize because my co-host uh
reza is not here today yeah why isn't he
here i thought we were
oh
he was i actually called him this
morning and he was he was researching
you and he was really excited to talk to
you and actually called you to tell you
that and just what i picked up since
we're talking about creativity and
trauma
is to dive a little deeper um i heard
uh some hesitation in your voice when i
said reza's name and you know reza pp pm
madagende koshkesh tuk masad that's a
persian power persian mafia um represent
you went to a school
with lots of persians yeah and um
beverly hills high school and yeah and
we lived in the slums of beverly hills
don't get me wrong we're mostly from
koreatown but for a few years i was
there yeah and lots of reza's there
that's where i lost my virginity
that's actually um that's what i
remember you telling me and uh
a lot of reza's a very common name and
freshman year of high school
the reza that was the all-star
quarterback of the varsity team i didn't
know persians played football yeah
um
that
pummeled you almost to an inch of your
life how do you know this you just told
me david you just told me on the phone
today wow
so um
uh two black eyes internal bleeding
broken nose
um absolute humiliation wow uh one of
the biggest traumas in your life
in front of thousands of kids thousands
well it's a humongous high school
uh and it was on the front lawn
and so when i told you that res is not
feeling well and he's not going to make
it today i i i felt some relief because
that word is very triggering for you oh
that's what i picked up so yeah um
well this has been part of my process is
kind of learning about triggers and um
you know i've talked about it before on
a lot of different podcasts on joe rogan
rich roll
you know many many others and uh
you know i talked a lot about you know
kind of
getting sober and getting therapy and
dealing with my uh sexual abuse that
happened to me when i was younger and
the trauma that i've undergone
so
this is part of it you know
these things these real trauma i believe
what i've learned through the
therapeutic process trauma lives
in your body you know and um
uh
so i hear the word reza and
literally like if a doctor had you know
uh a pulsometer on me like my heart rate
would go up a little bit my blood
pressure would go up a little bit
um
because that was so it wasn't and it
wasn't the pain
you know it was the humiliation it was
like oh
you were the little korean kid who got
the [ __ ] beat out of you by reza the
quarterback and um
you know i never lived it down i mean it
was years later kids at beverly hills
high school would be like uh
oh reza or they'd make a persian joke or
something like that so
you know this i'm not saying that i'm
racist against persians i'm just saying
that
there's a lot of just racist against the
name reza
yeah i'm kind of racist against names
you know someone earlier was saying that
tyler's editing
you know
the uh this episode and um and i was
like i hate that name tyler i
immediately disliked tyler mm-hmm um i
heard you say that because it just
sounds like an entitled little
millennial white kid
ladies and gentlemen of the metaphysical
milkshakes this podcast is sponsored by
better help is there something
interfering with your happiness or
something that's
preventing you from achieving your goals
why yes as a matter of fact rain there
is i've uh you know lately i've been
i've been dealing with uh some anxiety
this weird weird anxiety that comes out
of nowhere in the middle of the night uh
and uh
i think i probably need to start seeing
someone about it why not try better help
because betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist and you
can start communicating in under 48
hours
better help is not a crisis line it's
not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online that's
right the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log in to your
account anytime and send a message to
your counselor and you'll get a timely
and thoughtful response betterhelp is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if and
when needed it's also more affordable
than traditional
offline counseling and there is also
financial aid available betterhelp wants
you to start living a happier life today
so visit their website read the
testimonials that are posted daily visit
betterhelp.com slash milkshake that's
better h-e-l-p
and join the over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help that they're now
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states so don't forget the special
offer for metaphysical milkshake
listeners you can get 10 off your entire
first month
at betterhelp.com
milkshake betterhelp.com milkshake
what was i talking about and you know
there's so this is i'm in i'm in a
process hold on a second i'm in a
process a multi-year process of
untangling unpacking these traumas and
these triggers to try and figure out
what makes me tick because for many many
years these traumas owned me the shame
around the traumas owned me they drove
my behavior i did a lot of stuff that
i'm really not proud of
and so i'm trying to unpack all of that
so even this opportunity to just come up
against the name reza allows me to air
that out and say i have resentment
against this kid this was humiliating i
you know
even right now
i feel really
i get i can feel
15 year old
david and what that felt like
a broken tooth blood running down my
face
laughter the kids
and once again i am told the story of
you're a failure
you're a piece of [ __ ]
no one cares about you you're
contemptible
you're hated you'll never fit in
and now you know what
i get to feel those emotions
i get to
i get to go through this
i have the bounty luxury
the ability to go
i had a
therapist once told me the only way out
is through
and so i get to go through
and i get to find out what's on the
other side which is
i am loved i am accepted i am not a
failure
i love myself
i
can be a part of
groups i will be accepted by people
and
i can forgive reza
the quarterback
and reza the podcast host
[Music]
i can forgive
because
i am enough
guys um dj can you change this to a red
background please um cho that was
i just want to tell you right now
i love you
um you came in hot a little bit today
like i don't know if it was the traffic
and i know
i know how much work you've put into
yourself and how much therapy you've
gone to i know how much
years years of work
still when you sat down today sounded so
angry and i'm really glad you got to
unpack a lot of that stuff and i just
wanted to tell you
to echo what you just said is
you are enough
thank you you you are enough
you're worthy and you're enough and
and um
you know thank you for being so
vulnerable thank you for sharing that
with me i i really
was feeling everything you were saying
right now and
um
actually
it really um
echoed a lot of my story of how i felt
growing up
alienated isolated and how i howl
and and how that manifested in so many
dysfunctional ways in my life and how
being an artist and and acting was such
a
a relief and an escape from from
how i could funnel all these emotions
that you just
openly
shared with me
how i put that into my art
so thank you for that well i never
thanks thank you rain
i never would have
you know if this was five years ago and
i'd had those emotions
you know i don't know what i would
have done with them i would have taken
them out they would have come out come
out sideways in some way
yeah i've i've heard old uh you know
howard stern and yeah in your own
podcast that used to do and it was just
it sounded like a uh
just someone that was in so much pain
yeah and didn't know how to deal with it
and a lot of that i can see when i see
your paintings
but
um
you're enough and i'm glad you're here
and thanks and you don't have to like
put on a dance and be entertaining and
and you know i i just love you just as
you are
you know what i want to do for you rayne
because i appreciate this so much what's
that um
my paintings
sell for
minimum to 300 000 all the way up into
the millions i don't really have them on
the market but i want to give you
your choice of any one of my paintings
wow you can come into the warehouse wow
as a gift to you
or you can sell it for your non-profit
oh my god
you can have are you serious your pick
of any one of my paintings
that's how much when you don't care if i
ever resell it or anything this
conversation well i'd prefer you didn't
resell it unless it was some kind of
like charity auction wow that's the only
stipulation because there's a certain
price
settings that has to do with the gallery
art market [ __ ] world which i'm just
starting to kind of figure out and get
into but
oh my god i i mean that's so generous
thank you so much i've
i never thought i would own a show and i
know you don't sell your art so wow
jesus wow
thank you um
um
i'd like to accept i would actually i
would love to accept because you're my
friend and your art means so much to me
but um
and this is my own work i need to do
um
there's too much of your art
that reminds me of my father's art
so i can't hang it in my house
so i'm gonna have to
respectfully decline no i think you're
gonna have to
yeah you're gonna have to take one of
those
yeah you just yeah you have to get over
that so
we can get some therapy together all
right
i'll go see i'll go see first
and see unseen and red red red light hit
that oh yellow purple pink here we go
wow dude that's why he gets the big
bucks dude amazing
um we both kind of get the big bucks
although not in the podcast world
wow that was so good man i was that was
[ __ ] i was like
your face like your eyes started to turn
korean and i like even though you're
wearing sunglasses and
don't really resemble me like you i
thought i was looking at myself first um
ladies and gentlemen we did not
i think david had that up his sleeve i
had no idea that was gonna happen so we
were
how often am i am i gonna get to uh role
play and act with the great rain wilson
well any time anytime you want you know
when i pick up that painting
you we can i'll give you
some acting lessons um
once again welcome to metal metaphysical
milkshake uh part two uh i'm rayne
wilson with me as the great artist david
cho
um
you and i have been through a lot of
therapy um
we
went to a similar
through a similar kind of uh a program
that was really intensive where there
was a lot of like
psychodrama
uh etc like that and um
we've so we've talked about that in the
past it was a pleasure to kind of get to
share
that a little bit maybe we can do a
little bit more later on
i like to play that's true creativity
right like you said like i said earlier
you're one of the most creative people
that i know like creativity is
constantly vomiting out of you it's like
you're you're painting you're drawing
you're singing you're in a korean punk
band
right um you've done performance art
installation theater you've just made a
tv show um you're constantly uh
up to something creative and
uh
there's all these cliches about
creativity we talked about one of them
like creativity comes from trauma
although i don't know if that's a cliche
because it's born true out of just
thousands of
cases um
but also
art with art comes madness
the artist as madman and then the artist
and something that we've talked about a
lot in our in our friendship over the
last
six years or seven years however long
it's been um
uh
art artist as narcissist i know
narcissism is something that we deal
with so what do you think artists does
madman artist is narcissist are those
things necessary for creation let me
shake rain wilson out of me okay
um
i'm me again good hey hey everyone
um i
there's few things that are true which
is i am lactose intolerant
i did have diarrhea like moments right
before this podcast and i did have the
absolute living [ __ ] kicked out of me in
front of
thousands of kids because it was like um
the story the whole day around the
school was the varsity quarterback reza
is gonna kick the [ __ ] or is gonna fight
the weird dave cho
where rumor was going around that i had
ninja skills so it was going to be like
the strong so there's racism thrown in
as well yeah i mean that's anti-asian
racism yeah it was like it was like the
karate kid those movies were out and
they were like he's weird he keeps to
himself and we heard that he knows some
kind of like metaphysical like uh you
know martial arts skills
so it was a it was a big build up
and um
and so you want to talk about
well i just did your buddy rich roles
podcast about a month ago and uh
um
the question was
does
do you need to suffer to to create great
art and it's it's like one of these
questions that's always asked and
answers yes it's just yes
and so
if you're listening right now if you're
watching right now you're mentally ill
because only mentally ill people listen
to podcasts and
you're sick and
if you're talking about suffering and
trauma
we've had it
no one has had a perfect childhood no
one and that's what i've learned is
we we try to put trauma on as a
competition like oh this person had the
worst childhood this person
just didn't get the presents he wanted
for his birthday but all those things
are as our friend kevin likes to say
maximum to them and so
no one had a perfect childhood
everyone's been traumatized in their own
way so does it does it take trauma to
create something yes but the the thing
is
you've already had it
right like i'm
i i got stuck in a cycle where i'm like
i got the living [ __ ] kicked out of me
by this guy reza and i hated you you hit
it on the mark i hated how that made me
feel the black eyes healed the nose
healed the the pain
it sucked and then it went away the the
shame the humiliation lasted forever and
from that
i will never ever
make another human being make me feel
like that again ever
and how how do i do that do i go to the
gym do i learn actual ninja skills do i
no i'm not gonna do that but where do
where can i shine
when i draw when i draw girls notice me
my parents notice me everyone notices me
so if i can draw even better
then people like reza will never [ __ ]
with me or and what what are the things
that i can can accomplish by being a
great artist i can make money i can get
fame and once i'm an important enough
vip important person then people like
that won't [ __ ] with me they won't you
know so
that's the energy that that
absolutely created and then and then the
girlfriend you were dating the hottest
girl at beverly hills high school and
then she dumped you she dumped me and
and then she left you for not reza but
another football player right
and actually another persian football
player but she left you for another
production yeah i didn't know that there
was this union of persian there was a
lot of versions of the pm persian mafia
pp persian power and i actually love
persian food i love persian people you
know japanese food my number one
favorite number two
persian food
uh it's so good and it's little
appreciated kebab
all the dishes the stews it's amazing
i i'll just i just lied right now so
i'll back up because i just want to
correct that i [ __ ] hated perch
people right like you did yeah you just
nailed it got the living [ __ ] kicked out
of me in high school then my
girl my first girlfriend that i was
completely in love with left me for a
persian so of course i hated persians i
hated their culture i hate everything
about them i don't today currently i
love them i love persians i love
everything about the culture but
i did that's true that's a true
statement i did hate persian people i
don't anymore
it's not even a debate it's not even a
question if that didn't happen would i
still be an artist yes but it wouldn't
have the level of intensity and
creativity of
what can i do i i feel so lost right now
i feel so hurt
i feel so so much pain right now on this
podcast yes and back then i'm tapping
into it but at that time you know
heartbroken the worst thing you could
feel [ __ ] beat out of you those broken
mock mocked mocked
and so the and the racist stuff and the
racism
yeah shame humiliation like everything i
don't know what to do with this level of
pain
uh you know i didn't do it but you know
suicidal thoughts as a you know
very emo high school kid and so i poured
it
into my paintings and my drawings on a
level that i never would have if those
things didn't happen yeah but those so
so then i'm 45 now and i'm talking about
things that happened 30 years ago three
decades ago and i could let him go i can
have this conversation with you yeah but
i didn't i didn't five years ago six
seven years ago
seven years ago i didn't i would keep
repeating the trauma so the question
comes does great art require suffering
and the answer is yes but you've already
suffered if you're watching this right
now you've suffered you have you you
already went through the breakup you
already had the shitty parents you
already had all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
happened to you you don't have to keep
i'll use i statements i don't have to
keep repeating those things but i did i
would be stuck i was stuck being the key
word on a [ __ ] treadmill of trauma
where i just kept repeating this [ __ ]
over and over again because i was like
that's my pattern yeah i get [ __ ] with
i get hurt and then i'm gonna use that
as gasoline so where do your parents fit
into that
oh i mean they they are the most
loving wonderful people and monsters at
the same time
like it's true i mean i love my mom i'll
[ __ ] die for her i'll do anything for
her and she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's both
things and
you know i i i get to
um i'm very brave when i talk about her
that way because i know she doesn't
listen to metaphysical milkshake and if
she was listening right now i would
never say that
but yeah my that was
like my father my father anyone who
knows my dad he's like
he's like a funny goofy your parents are
sweethearts yeah they're like adorable
you just want to hug them but one day
my dad beat the living [ __ ] out of me
holy [ __ ] this is so crazy right now i
swear to god this was not planned
my dad beat the [ __ ] out of me
because i had holes in my jeans
and if you remember the 90s or the late
80s that was cool right right people
would do that on purpose they would buy
jeans but you came from a poor family
right holes and pants meant and i
peasant exactly i don't know what you
know and this is me trying to like you
know figure out my you know what my
dad's day was
i don't know what his day was like i
don't know what it's like to not speak
english perfectly and try to raise three
boys in america so he came home one day
and saw me ripping brand new jeans that
you know i don't know like that's a lot
of money for him
and
he beat the living [ __ ] out of me he
said we're gonna go out tonight and
you're not wearing that
you know change and or where you know my
mom the thing that kept happening is i
kept ripping these holes in the jeans
and my mom kept patching them up with
with patches like flat flower patches
and
rainbow bright patches and i'm like do
you and to them it's like it's a hole
that needs to be fixed to me it's like
let this whole
[ __ ] gape me open this [ __ ] up you
know
and so i you know i was a rebellious
teenager i was like no this dad you're
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] from korea you
don't know you don't know what's cool
right now he's like no son of mine is
leaving the house looking like a peasant
and so i said you know i didn't say [ __ ]
you but i pretty much said no i'm and i
started walking out the door
and
he picked me up
and he threw me across the room
and he just started punching me which um
you know like he spanked me and [ __ ] and
like we got like that type of typical
korean uh abuse growing up which you
know once
also i could be like oh that's just part
of our culture you know but he never
like punched me he never like fist
fighted me you know and so he's like
punching me and like
he just kind of his face changed to a
different person
and um
you know
the reason why i brought it over is like
i'm i'm wearing pants like covered in
you know these pants cost 900 bucks but
they look like peasant pants but
they're like made those pants cost 900
yeah
they're like for real yeah for real
they're like vintage like i feel like
beating the [ __ ] out of you right now
for wearing 900 dollar pants hey guys
change the lights to strobe lights and
i'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of rain
right now um
no but that informed my style right that
trauma informs like me wearing
clothes that are like ridiculously
expensive but still look like i'm
homeless right
my brain goes my dad was 99.9 awesome
and one time he kicked my ass so let's
just forget about that part and anytime
a therapist try to bring it up or anyone
try to bring it up i'd be like why are
you trying to turn my dad into like a
bad guy he's not you know and it's not
about
my dad being a bad guy it's just about
just
accepting that that did happen and not
hiding from it and addressing it and
then moving on from it and uh i've done
that now i've
been in rooms
where people have played my dad where
i've played my dad and so i've worked
through it because i you know the korean
way to apolo because i know he's sorry
but the typical asian ways to never say
sorry but to like make you dinner or
something like do like some kind of
action to show hey i love you and i'm
sorry but i'm literally never going to
say the word so i'm sorry
so
well i relate so much to your story um i
i'm a pretty good actor i don't consider
my in all honesty i don't consider
myself anywhere near your level of like
brilliance i think i'm a good character
actor but that's something that's worth
something but it was the exact same
thing for me i never felt like i fit in
i always felt i had the [ __ ] beat out of
me in junior high school several times
i always felt lift left out i felt
alienated
at home my parents were in a loveless
marriage they were very odd human beings
a lot of kind of emotional developmental
issues and whatnot
and when i moved to this new high school
and i took my first acting class all of
a sudden i found out i was really good
at it and i was brand new i made people
laugh and all the girls came over
and were like i might have told this
story before i apologize if i have if
i've heard it on before on this and all
these cute young women came over and
were like who are you what's your name
you're so funny will you sit at our
lunch table and they were putting their
hand i'll never forget like just the
feeling of like their hands on my
shoulder like oh and i and i was like
getting these like literally physical
strokes for like an attention
and then i started dating some of them i
dated two or three of the of the
attractive ones and at my old high
school you know girls really didn't want
anything to do with me and then so all
of a sudden i was just like screw all
the nerd crap
i'm going into
acting
and i threw myself in the same way you
threw yourself into drawing maybe there
wasn't quite as much anger behind it but
it was kind of like i am never going to
feel that way again i'm never going to
feel left out again i think there was
just as much anger you're one of the
angriest dudes i know
i'm never going to feel
like belittled again or looked down upon
again or or the weirdo again or if i am
the weirdo i'll be embraced for being
the weirdo and guess what i am embraced
for being the weirdo because i'm
naturally offbeat and then i got to play
characters including dwight that are
offbeat and so
so here we are so there is
there is that fuel
you know i told you a little bit earlier
you are enough when i you were me so
basically saying um you're enough to
myself
but you're enough
i still battle with that no but you
really are and you are brilliant and i i
i believe that
i believe that about you i've seen you
i've seen your brilliance and your heart
and what you do i did do a pretty
[ __ ] brilliant david joe earlier that
was pretty good man yeah i mean i i
relate to all of that you know i
remember
the first
contact wasn't even a hand it was like i
was drawing something and it was just
like i i was i was so shy back then i
would never show to him but i was
drawing it like really small in my
sketchbook and a girl saw like the level
of detail and she came in close and her
hair
like touched my shoulder and i was like
holy [ __ ] like
this girl that is really attractive is
getting close to me because she wants to
see what i'm doing and i was like
this is this is the business i need to
go in yeah this is it
it was the same with me just leave it
leave it behind
but
there's something else i want to talk to
you about um
and then we can uh
talk more about your mother
but um
i have two things i want to say you've
been getting a lot of therapy recovery
you're a different person today you're
in a long-term relationship you have a
kid you're
um
best part best like the happiest i've
ever been in my life happiest fear have
been by the way you're looking really
felt and and fit right now thank you um
and
are you but you're making less art
and do you feel less creative
do you feel like
if you know new york city said hey we
want you to do a mural in the middle of
times square like could you go
kick ass could you
you know
can you can you find
can you tap into that creative vein so
being balanced part of your life right
now part of
um
one of the programs in ga the gambler's
anonymous program
because i'm a severe gambling addict and
one of the things that i learned as a
gambler is you got to get out while
you're ahead
right and so
um
there's a there's they teach that at
gambler's anonymous i don't know that
they teach i don't think gamblers don't
teach that but that's like hi i've just
mortgaged my home and no no michael my
face kicked me out of the house like hey
buddy you got to get out where you're at
they don't teach you no one to hold them
and know when to fold them buddy yeah
it's in the pamphlets they don't teach
you that but i learned that as a gambler
and i try to apply that to all there's
something i'm 45 years old and no
disrespect to the old school heads out
there but there's something sad to me
about a 45 year old graffiti artist
so i could i do a giant mural in new
york times i i first of all i care about
my health i want to live long
spray painting doing murals is some of
the most toxic paint in the you know
like i have smoker's lungs and i've
never smoked a cigarette in my life
just from the aerosol and i i paint
mostly you might as well start smoking i
mean you got the lungs for it so i paint
mostly in watercolors
and um
you know when you were doing this
brilliant job playing me earlier
you know you got a few details wrong but
you had tapped directly
into
i felt you man i was i was there i was
feeling it all again so
with me being at the
best like in my opinion the best i've
ever felt i'm the happiest i've ever
been the the
this is the best part of my life right
now
there is a narrative that just screams
so your art must be shitty then because
you don't got that thing you don't got
that
to like you have no part of you that
needs to prove your because you know why
because you're enough you don't need to
show off you don't need to do the every
[ __ ] hair on that portrait you could
just and abstract it in you know like
so that that's a narrative but the truth
is like i was saying does you know great
art require suffering i've already
suffered you've already suffered so just
like the way you did right there i can
tap into it you get it you can get it i
can tap into it at any time i don't have
a great answer i could just tap into it
and
and
you know i just talked to stevo on his
podcast and i've had a similar question
where you guys almost get offended
when i go have you ever done
a great you know in stevo's case a stunt
or acted or or in my case a painting
where it was just for you where it
wasn't for an audience where it wasn't
need to be validated i struggled with
that and the answer is like in stevo's
case he was almost like [ __ ] you like
why would you even ask me that of course
it does it's like it didn't even happen
if no one saw it and i'm
if i'm really
and the thing is
if you see me on a hike i hike a lot i'm
literally saying out loud i'm enough
while i'm hiking that's like kind of
like i'm like i'm enough i'm enough and
and then i start to really believe it
because the first time i said it or the
first time you said it to me or someone
else said it to me i didn't believe it
and i still struggle with it but if it
is true that it's enough
then
it is actually
the most creative time in my life
because i have thousands of drawings
thousands that no one's ever seen and i
do them just for with my with my baby
and
like
like if i'm playing with her
i go
okay
i could just dial it in right now read
her a book do you know just do normal
dad [ __ ] or i can just create a [ __ ]
insane magical world for right now
audience of one right but that takes
time it's gonna take hours i'm gonna
have to make this costume and it's like
oh i should film it or you know i should
you know my brain goes into like my mom
jane cho marketing like oh then i should
make a children's book and monetize it
you know and i go
i can't i got to get over myself and go
this is something that's just for me and
my family
oh [ __ ] but people should see it and
it's gonna get so many views and it can
make money and
but in my in my opinion
it's the most creative i've been it's
just it's not for an audience it's not
for everybody but i would
wouldn't want to argue like
if you're yo-yo ma and you're the most
brilliant cellist and creating and
you're creating a symphony in your
closet right and you're creating the
most beautiful music you've ever created
in your life and you're like
and you're creating all this incredible
music
don't you also have an obligation
to share that beauty with someone whose
heart might be touched by it and it
might affect their life and change them
in some way enough
you are enough
this is what you just said right now is
what i also struggle with
is
when you say that
my ego my narcissism goes absolutely
dude so i should spend more time
trying to get it out to the people and
that's why
i struggle with how much
tv
but don't you know isn't what you what
you struggle with what we struggle with
balance
so you're doing this art there is no
chance there is no balance that is
in my opinion
there's no balance people go oh you know
they hear your problems they hear about
life and they go
hey you know what you need in your life
you need to just balance like you know
have a few vegan meals and you know you
can eat one cheat meal
the people that i hang out with or i
i'll say i statements again i've never
had balance when i'm in i'm in and it's
something i've tried i've taken classes
i've read books of like how do i balance
it's like
and maybe i'm not there yet or maybe i
haven't had met the person that can do
it properly yet like yeah but you like
veganism you you went all in on veganism
because you got a bad report from your
doctor so you went vegan for several
months and then you gave up on veganism
and then you were just eating
cheeseburgers for months well that's
what i'm saying there's no balance right
and so you have people that touch
people's lives like and and i've never
met gabor mate but i know you talked to
him
like a guy like that who's just full of
empathy and wisdom and he can touch and
change people's lives and you're like oh
like
but
is he healthy i mean he looks really
skinny and this is me jumping to
assumptions and judging but some of
these people
um and that's my like i said that's my
own narcissism and
i i sit there and i've played
you know like i said it's it's been an
explosion of creativity the last five
six years so i have movies no one's ever
seen i have tv shows no one's ever seen
i have books no one's seen i have
hundreds of podcasts no one's ever heard
and when i played for you but you have a
autobiography that no one's ready i have
a book that's you know i have things and
i go
my ego and my narcissism says
people need to to see this because it
will change lives because i've done
other art where i get fan mail and
people go this changed my life this
changed my life and
i go
what about me right now
is it selfish is it narcissistic to be
like i don't want to go into
marketing branding promo mode right now
i just wanna like i did the work
one day it'll be out in the world one
day maybe when i'm more or or maybe i'll
just put it out when i die or
what about just me getting healthy and
spending time with my family and that's
what i'm doing right now no one can deny
you that but i would say and i want to
lead to the next question and then we
can uh uh go to the next section um
and that is um
you know
let's say
there's uh some kind of
great creative force spirit
cosmic spirit in the universe
and this great creative force
wants us to be less self-involved and
more giving to others
so less selfish less me oriented which
is kind of the modern disease it's me me
me me
but
you know like on the airplane they you
know you have to put the
oxygen mask on your own face first
before you put the oxygen mask on
someone else that frequently used
analogy so you have to get better so
that you can serve others but then the
goal would be
to use your art to make to enrich other
people's lives it's not about you it's
about it's about others not a and eve
but it's not narcissism either because
it's not about the glory it's not about
the fame like how does this reflect on
me it's got to be given in that pure
spirit of giving and you said and part
two of that is you had a quote
creativity is god when i am creating
that's me
praying
and that is very similar um
to a quote from the baha'i faith which
is that art is the same as prayer that
one when one puts the paintbrush to the
paper it is is it is the same thing as
kneeling in the temple
central quote from the baha'i faith so
so are there korean baha'i
there's i'm i've i know a couple of
questions
maybe i'll be the first one
um i like that quote um i'll say so so
those are the two things like
priest let's presuppose the existence of
some kind of higher power that higher
power wants us to give back and also is
art
divine is that where you find your
connection to the higher power in the in
the act of it itself is there a
sacredness there a divinity absolutely
to me transcendence absolutely to me art
can transcend it and it is definitely
sacred
um but to
um
i'll plug my own show right now i have a
show on hulu right now called the cho
show and
um
i believe
that is the act of me being creative and
giving back
and
it's only four episodes which actually
it isn't it's you know i've interviewed
uh over a thousand people in
[Music]
the last seven years so there's way more
than four episodes
but
because
shame is such a powerful drug in our in
our culture
and people use it in different ways some
people run to it some people run away
from it
people
that i interview they opened up they
shared their
souls
and immediately regretted it and they
said i can't have this out i can't have
the world see this you had a number of
people who recorded with you signed
releases thank you for not being one of
the people that pulled powers in front
of cameras bears their souls and then
were like oh [ __ ] no yeah
so um so there's a bit of
and the reason and the thing is i do it
so openly all the time and i'm so used
to it that i don't think about it and
you know i i can
i've spent enough time
with these issues where i can talk
openly about my sexual abuse
all the abuses the spiritual abuse the
religious abuse and all these things
that happen to me um in a way where i
can talk about it and i and i get
strength from it but a lot of people
still don't
they they
don't want to wear it they don't want to
talk about it they
you know
so so i get it so when i put a show out
like that
there's a part of me
that says am i actually helping people
because the actual people that i thought
i was helping on the show that i
interviewed
they're saying the show is hurting them
then can you please not put it out
so you're helping that audience that's
seen the show people love the show right
so they write to you they talk about
this was i needed to hear this well that
goes back to the narcissism and like
kind of the martyrdom it's like i'm
gonna sacrifice myself and like the way
people uh see me and all all the guests
on my show so that it can help all these
people and there's something that i'm
still trying to figure out about that
uh about
you know basically going to all your
last questions of
the creativity is done the show's done
right like it took me more work to get
the show on tv than to actually make the
show and the show you know it has like
over 40 000 hand-drawn animation like
it's
it's it's a lot of work and and yet it
was more work to get it on tv
and we live in a weird culture right now
where
you know i'll hang out with you i'll
hang out with other creative people and
it will be present with each other i'm
with you i mean i i get that we're
recording this right now but you know
outside of this we'll be together and
something amazed someone will do
something funny or someone will sing a
song and that feeling of someone's being
creative right now someone's talking to
god right now
can it just be that or do we have to put
it up on social media and that's the
fight it's like man something amazing is
happening right now i gotta share it
with the world because i'm enjoying it
so everyone else should enjoy it and
and i struggle with that and you know
part of that now is i have a child safe
phone and and i block myself from that
so i i'm
saying about the balance earlier it
hasn't existed for me yet but i'm still
working on it
and for me
who
is from a family with tons of uh
religious abuse and spiritual abuse i've
never heard those terms before i'd only
heard sexual abuse physical abuse verbal
mental issues and i and i grew up in a
family that like that i was i i thought
sometimes i was satan i slumped
sometimes i thought i was gonna burn in
hell and it's it's
it's um
it's insane
when we go to like the treatment centers
did your family tell you that you were
gonna burn in hell yeah i mean that's
very clear in the christian religion if
you do not accept jesus christ as your
personal lord and savior you will go did
your mom tell you that uh
yes yes in a very nice way but that was
still the message
i remember joey who was jewish my best
friend growing up coming over
and um
and you know i'd like to you know put my
mom on the spot so she'd be cooking
dinner for us and i'm like mom joey's
jewish is he gonna burn in hell and
she's like absolutely you want some you
want some kimchi
you know she's just that person so she
would deliver the message you know with
a little song and dance but it was still
yeah you're gonna smell the brimstone
like it's happening
so i grew up with these kinds of things
and then
i end up
in like these treatment centers in my
mind i judge before i get there i'm like
man there's gonna be some really [ __ ]
up people there like suicidal drug
addicts and i get there and all those
people are there
and you hear their stories of
sexual abuse
physical abuse and at the end and you
know i keep saying trauma's not not a
competition but then i'm like
why is there so many hasidic jews here
why is there so many mormons here why is
there so many you know
cat you know like strict religious and
and you're like wait at the at the at
the bottom of all this abuse is like
this religious abuse
so for someone like me who has all this
negative
connotations with religion and
spirituality
it's very hard to pray it's very hard to
like get in touch with the higher powers
and and you know i i think i'm spiritual
and then like i'll try to meditate and
just my mind starts thinking about yeah
pornographic images or something i can't
clear my mind i remember
the late great director roger michelle
he just passed away i got to work with
him he's a terrific film director
um
we were touring this church in england
and he said oh so you're a baha'i
i was like yeah what do you he's like
you believe in god and i was like yeah
and he goes
i said what about you and he's like oh
no i could never believe in god you know
um when i was a kid i was dragged to
church every day i had to be a choir boy
i had to
you know practice this and that i had to
be in the church choir and oh oh god i
could never believe in god
and so he had fused these two
he this brilliant well-read brilliant
guy yeah in those sentences couldn't
disassemble right
i had religious abuse thrown on at me
growing up and
do i believe in god sent us
and those get welded and i understand
why some of the smartest most brilliant
people i've ever met are the dumbest
people i've ever met in my life and i
you know i i
it takes like a team of people for me to
keep coming back to
get me to figure out like
oh man this is i'm bringing a lot of
baggage to this thing and
one day i was just going for a walk
and i was like man i'm having a real
hard time like i feel like i'm a
spiritual person but i just can't get
there and it's just
i'm like man i live in a city and humans
is like all these people they're just
sad and they have addictions and they
have mental illness and and they just
can't figure their [ __ ] out and this and
that and we just live in this godless
world and [ __ ] porn every you know
and internet and so you know it's just
like it feels so heavy and and through
all of that i go
that act of getting on your hands and
knees and putting your hands together
it's tough for me
but i'm like what when i when i see this
person who can't sing but like really
try to sing or someone who designed an
amazing building with flying buttresses
or someone who who from the depth of
their soul can belt out i'm like
oh that's praying
like
us these sad humans that live in this
[ __ ] horrible time in the world with
all this crazy [ __ ] happening
what what like what stops that right
what crosses and transcends all barriers
races it's like when [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
and then someone like
can sing amazing or someone can like
creatively bring a new energy to a sport
or design a new car or
you know just
i'm like holy [ __ ] like you feel like
what are you trying you're transcending
everything because you're
you're literally talking to god at that
moment i and that's what i feel like and
people call it different things like
flow state or it's like when you have
all this noise and [ __ ] but you're like
wait for this second
i'm gonna
try to write a song and sing it even
though i can't sing or i'm gonna
well i've had this idea in my head it's
where is that coming from
and
for me i'm like oh
that's what prayer is that's what makes
sense to me and in that way i love god
and and i worship god because
that's what i do i draw i create and i
try
to bring creativity to every part of my
life so that means i'm praying all the
time
david cho
this has been an absolute honor but
before we end the show
um we have one more segment that we need
to do so this is rayne wilson we've had
the brilliant and very korean david cho
here today wow thank you for sharing all
that that was that was a lot you know uh
i i think our listeners will really
appreciate you i could keep going for
another three hours i i know and i know
that me coming we could get all rogan on
this i know me trying to cut you off
right now i can sense that you're you're
feeling like you're being rejected but i
i loved it um i am enough tyler you are
enough tyler can you please cut at least
uh 40
50 of what is everything he said today
uh rain uh
i'm rain and um
david the way we like to end the last
sip of metaphysical milkshake is
lightning round and you guys know what
this is so david uh i hope you're ready
uh i'm gonna shoot you i'll see what
happens yeah just just the first thing
that comes to your mind okay okay
when do you feel the most connected with
the universe
um in nature you know if i'm able to
hear birds sing i feel like i'm part of
something bigger than myself
um what skill do you wish you had
um i wish i could build things you know
i wish i could fix things i wish that
like there's a a leak under the sink i
wish that i could just like grab a tool
box and like
you know
fix it and stuff like that like i'm good
with paint brushes i can build a canvas
you know i can create sculpture but why
can't i like fix a door hinge
uh what is the happiest what was the
happiest day of your life
uh
the birth of my child
wow
um
how come you're the best
i'm not the best i am how come you're
the best you are enough
you are the best now answer how come
you're the best i i reject that question
that fuels my narcissism we've talked
about that i am a humble worker among
workers what is your greatest wish or
desire
oh a world peace
be
to
find
uh
to continue to find uh happiness joy and
serenity in the in my making of art
wondering what my next chapter is gonna
be what why what one eye-opening
experience should every person have
um
i was in a japanese prison um
for shoplifting
and that was one of the times i really
hit bottom it was
very very dark
and i won't say that i wish that on
everyone to be in a japanese prison we
think oh japanese they're so polite and
they're nice and
wonderful prepared sushis and you know
beautiful downtown like oh their prisons
have got to be nice the worst
the worst
um
it scarred me and yet it gave me a
perspective that i'm really grateful for
so you described like a kind of
purgatory which brings us to our next
question what happens to us when we die
our uh our consciousness
uh detaches from this meat suit that
we're
riding around in for 90 plus years
and you're an artist i'm sure you have a
very visual description in your head of
what
nirvana heaven afterlife looks like
right well we know picture all of the
greatest colors you've ever seen in your
life and the greatest music your very
favorite music symphony radio head
whatever it is
that's happening and the most beautiful
aromas you can ever picture and then and
then know that whatever is in the next
plane of existence for our
consciousnesses there's at least seven
other
layers of perception beyond what i just
described so creep on repeat with like
the smell of not create fresh uh comic
books no no no in rainbows
what one tip can you can you give
parents that would help their children's
happiness
uh listen to them
and last question
is everything gonna be okay
no
wow dave what a way to end the show see
because i feel like if i was you raine
would have said yes but i'm david show i
would say no you are david cho and that
is a very david show answer
and a real david show answer would to be
do the opposite of that so it's yes
thanks for having me on your show oh yes
everything's gonna be okay guys yes
love you brother
love you ring
you aren't enough
you're enough
[Music]
whoa uh
that was unlike any episode of
metaphysical milkshake we've ever done i
have two
immediate observations i'm never letting
you do this solo again
okay and now that i think about it i do
remember punching a an asian kid named
david when i was i'm just kidding no it
wasn't me it wasn't me david
i think he is kind of a better rain
wilson than i am
i'm not gonna disagree with that i think
he could fill in for me and just pretend
to be me
and uh we would not even skip a beat
yeah maybe like me him and all those
facebook uh stock options
can uh start doing our own little thing
i'm up for it is what i'm trying to say
but to this larger question i thought it
was very very fascinating this idea of
the relationship between trauma and
creativity i mean what did you think
you've had a lot of trauma in your life
and you are an enormously creative
person i mean
is it true then is that
truly what unlocks creativity is trauma
i have worked with many
amazing artists
that
seemingly did not have much trauma as
children
you know
i don't steve carell i still could get
to know better but he had loving parents
and a warm family environment and went
to a nice college and he is a genius he
is one of the greatest actors i've ever
worked with and he can bring any
character to life
so you know the jury is out but i know
for me
that if i had been raised with a perhaps
a more loving connected family
and a little bit less poverty and maybe
a little bit
less uh
kind of physical fear uh in my household
that perhaps
i would have just been happy
working in a shoe store as an adult and
i wouldn't have needed to uh pursue
acting i did really related uh you know
when david and i shared those stories
about
the girls you know he he he drew art
because it got him positive attention
from females and i went into acting
because
all of a sudden
attractive young girls in high school
noticed me because i was funny and i was
entertaining in improvisations in an
acting class and
so there is that kind of i don't know
that that missing gene perhaps in in
artists wanting to be noticed loved
appreciated and diving into our art uh
so that we actually have a sense of
self-worth i mean we spoke about that
whole phrase i am enough and how hard
that is i mean do you struggle with that
reza at all like can you say
we're putting aside the books you're
writing the screenplays you're writing
the tv shows you're producing the
podcasts you're occasionally doing
um
uh putting all that aside can you say
you know with um a peaceful heart i am
enough who
well you know again as uh as long-time
listeners of the pod know
i'm still dealing with gabor mate
uh
dissecting dissecting me making me
realize that i am a serious workaholic
so i'm still dealing with that so
i gotta be honest with you enough
isn't in my vocabulary
it just doesn't exist enough doesn't
exist whatever
whatever success i have whatever
goal i achieve i don't i don't even take
the time to enjoy it because i'm already
like next
um but maybe and you you know you had
trauma yeah right so you're an immigrant
family living in oklahoma
yeah um in a culture that is like you
better be successful at all costs for
the pride of the family and the
financial support of the family so
perhaps that's what it is perhaps that
trauma isn't so much about oh it makes
you a great artist it makes you feel
like i am not enough unless i accomplish
man this is exactly the kind of question
i want our audiences
to respond to what you guys out there a
lot of you are creatives a lot of you
are creatives in different ways but you
know you use your brain and your
imagination a lot of you have a lot of
drive
what i mean what do you think it is
trauma a sort of natural propulsion
for these kinds of
um
journeys that like you know people like
rayne and i have have gone on are you
someone who has experienced trauma and
then turn that trauma
into success in your field
or are you like a steve carrell or like
my wife jessica jackly you know who like
had like the storybook childhood and is
just as successful
let us know and brilliant and brilliant
and beautiful
i don't know about steve corral my wife
is beautiful i don't know he's a
beautiful he's kind of good-looking
that's true
milkshakers as you know uh rain and i
always like to remind you that if you
rate and review our show on apple
podcast or wherever you listen to find
podcasts and you ask us a question uh in
the review section
and we like your question who knows we
may actually have you come on and ask
the question
uh to us personally and
we might even answer the question no
guarantees there we may not answer the
question we may just tell you to [ __ ]
off
but at least you'll get to ask the
question and
uh this week uh we had a great question
from
a man named casey from casey casey from
kc hey guys how you doing hey um casey
uh you're a big metaphysical milkshake
fan what's your favorite episode so far
ben folds one that i just watched yeah
that's a good one the reason i responded
to your tweet a couple weeks ago asking
for questions is because it was really
like
rain wilson and benfold's
colliding is like two parts of my
uh you know pop cult like just my world
just colliding so i i had to get in okay
but here's here's the real question did
you
go and listen to uh lightning bugs ben
folds his podcast not yet so you gotta
do that because like the if you love the
ben folds podcast that kind of concludes
it brings ben's
podcast and in that podcast you get to
hear ben folds and rayne wilson do a a
piano
bassoon duet come on america so i mean
like that that's like that's got to be
your fantasy right i mean casey what
brings you here today you've got you've
got a question you've got an issue what
do you want to talk about you know 200
years from now and beyond what are the
habits activities cultural norms that we
all take part and we can focus on usa i
mean because
globally it would be different but for
us in the united states
those activities and norms that are
commonplace today that 200 years and
beyond
people will look back and
um in disgrace on us or they will
strongly frown upon us oh um that's a
fun question you know the the obvious
example if you go to the extreme is
slavery sure
slavery they didn't
at the time it's very true casey we we
do frown upon slavery today well there's
a whole field of study of of futurology
i don't know
it has some fancy name i forget what it
is that's where it's people will
speculate on the future and in fact
there's a ho there's a
i wish i had this here maybe one of the
producers can google it for me but
there's a conference where every year
people get together and they say here's
what's going to be happening in the
coming years but i love the idea that
you're going 200 years into the future
because it's kind of a specific number
it can you know no but i like 200 let's
stick with 200 because
um you know it's kind of the founding of
our of our country 200 years ago 200
years from now
um
it makes you think even bigger because
you know we're always thinking 10 years
20 years from now what will it be like
30 40 years so
200 years i can think of a couple of
things that are daily habits right now
that will people 200 years from now will
shake their head in disgust
and
incredible chagrin about one is
driving your your uh co2 emitting
exhaust emitting car carbon monoxide
emitting car
to a gas station and filling it with 20
to 30 gallons of petroleum
fluid which was you know
cultivated from organic matter deep
within drilled from the earth
and um
and
produced all this in the methane and the
making of it and then we're going to be
driving that car with with smoke coming
out of our tailpipes and you know
what is it 200 million cars in the
united states and all of that exhaust
going up into the atmosphere that is
going to be just like
did they understand what they were
talking about it's kind of like when we
see
nowadays we see trains that used to run
on coal you know and people riding in
the trains and like they're covered in
the soot from the coal blowing on them
it's kind of the same like wow people
used to get around like that that's
that's crazy or maybe like those the
railroad cars where the two people would
would do the bar you know like in the
silent movies and and push the railroad
car along i think that's one i think
another one
is going to be um
partisan politics and campaigning um
when you tabulate the
hundreds of millions of dollars every
year that are spent on
ads large and small it can be from a
presidential ad that runs during the
olympics to like a state senator ad that
just runs on local channels the making
of those ads the the the print campaigns
the billboards uh the the pop-up ads for
for for campaigns and this whole idea of
like a two-party system kind of being
interlocked
um in kind of right and wrong
with that whole kind of corrupt moneyed
system kind of promoting it i think in
the future people would be like what the
hell were they thinking all it created
was just
chaos and misery and
um
and uh disunity um so i think that's
that's another one on my on my list i
mean i think uh morals and values
obviously are gonna change dramatically
you know a hundred years ago
there was very little tolerance for
um homosexuality
uh interracial marriage was illegal
um
you know
uh
i think
morality more and more will probably be
disconnected from religion i think
religious identity
is probably going to
uh shift
uh
but i think if i were if i were to sort
of to give one prediction like one kind
of unusual prediction that i feel fairly
confident about but people probably
aren't thinking about when they think
about these things is i think that 200
years from now
there will be no such thing as the
nation state anymore
which is a weird thing to say
uh because like rain said 200 years ago
is kind of you know when america started
but i think that the concept of
the nation which is itself a very new
idea it's barely it's a little bit more
than 200 years old
i think will cease to exist
and i think
we will have um reached a level of kind
of post-nationalism
where
um
what you will have is a lot of
confederations in other words most of
the world will look like the european
union
right a bunch of semi-independent
states
that are
connected to each other by border and
probably share like a single currency a
single economy
uh in the case of the european union a
single birth certificate
you know and maybe even a single
parliament uh i think like they won't be
like the united states of america
anymore they'll be sort of like the
north american alliance
you know uh the african central african
alliance
uh eastern european
uh confederation
um and i think that's that's probably
how we will
um identify ourselves politically 200
years from now that that this hardcore
concept of like
nation and nationality will we'll look
back on it like the way that we look
back today on like empires like
no silly not silly british empire you
know so silly those people
uh that's how we'll look at nationality
and and then and the nation um i think
200 years from now
english is going to be the universal
language
um that everyone
around the globe is going to be raised
speaking their
national language or tribal language or
or state language or what have you
although i agree with reza that the idea
of states is going to be very different
200 years from now but they're also
going to learn english because right now
when you think about it english is the
language of like
international travel um
medical science um
and so many other uh sciences
you need um english to get by
and also you know culturally english is
very popular in terms of like rap music
and movies and whatnot and i think
humanity will just decide that english
is going to be kind of the universal
language that everyone is going to speak
now i'm not saying this in a kind of
like a
colonizer kind of english superiority
way i just
i kind of see this happening already
there's more english speakers in china
than there are in the united states
that's a fact i think it'll it'll make
uh
travel uh so much better um
for for everyone because even if you
grow up speaking english in you know
botswana and you want to travel to
singapore everyone there will still be
speaking english so it will make it feel
like we're all one species
to a much greater degree i mean look
this is great news on the one hand there
will be no such thing as america
on the other hand all
we lazy americans won't have to pretend
to try to learn other languages so it's
great for everyone casey what do you
what about you you've got to have some
thoughts on this yeah so the one example
if we go back to what will make us the
villains in 200 years and one that kind
of thought of was we buy all these
products that we
don't know we don't really think about
how they got made who made them the
conditions under which they were made
they obvious clothing
tech products won't name anything
specific but
i just wonder if in 200 years we'll look
back and say can you can you believe
that almost literally everybody in the
world perpetuated that
and bought these products while
uh you know people were suffering in in
these sweatshops across the globe and
things like that that's kind of a dark
thing to think about but kind of an
elimination of extremes of wealth and
poverty that this kind of rampant
consumerism in the west where we just
buy stuff with the click of a button
when
there's a couple billion people out
there that can't really buy
anything so
you think we'll really be that kind of
like spiritually mature in 200 years
that
that there will be
so much less of the halves and they have
nots
that's the next thought do
will these things get better will we
realize or
is all of it just going to get worse
and i don't know if i have the answer to
that i would i don't know 200 years from
now uh i just got back from a climate
conference uh sponsored by ted talks and
um
200 years from now we will have either
just finished going through or be in the
thick of
a climate
crisis that is going to be have just
world shaking ramifications in terms of
species extinction food chain issues
climate uh refugees
so humanity is going to be
severely tested um
beyond uh we've beyond ways that we've
ever been tested before so hopefully
we'll come out of that
more mature
and with greater uh compassion
and um and a lot less uh tribalism and
actually if you were looking for the
reason why i live in kansas city that's
it because i want to be as far away from
the rising oceans well done well played
yeah but you know what try the rocky
mountains you'll be you'll be it's even
better
casey thank you so much for coming on
metaphysical milkshake and um this was a
great question uh listeners we'd love to
hear from you you know contact us on our
social medias um
at rayne wilson at reza aslan at
metaphysical milkshake on instagram we'd
love to hear from you what do you think
is going to happen
what are your predictions your little
nostradamu
uh 200 years from now
and um
if you have your life's big question
that's eating away at you
let us know get in touch and we would
love to bring you on the show and i
promise next week i will be part of the
interview
oh thank you for dating us with your
presence reza the bully see you next
week everyone
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell cast media is
the production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by justin kyle original music is
composed by jeff tang
[Music]
i actually really wish rezza was here so
i could role play he could play like the
rezzo that beat me up and then i could
like beat him up in here and
yeah maybe it was good he didn't show up
today or maybe i could beat him up
through zoom zoom or whatever
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you